right oh sorry I've set the dog off good
start
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
just like to say that I will be trained
tonight's meeting in accordance with
normal practices and if we could move to
at first or if everybody could make sure
their phones are off or on silent
because sometimes we have been
interrupted by some unusual ringtones
but hopefully it won't be there tonight
and yeah that's right and I will be
checking my phone shortly once we start
on the first first item so if we go to
item 1 on the agenda apologies for
absence Thank You chairman one apology
from councillor Tommy Kendall chairman
Furman councillor Karbala substituting
and count for Donnell has been at the
hospital with the father all day and
she's going to get here as soon as she
can chairman I'd just like to introduce
the top table are my rights I've got
Allen CP from committee services who
will be keeping us under control
we've got my son ash from legal services
and to my left we've got David Jeffrey
and a whole bunch of planning officers
David million ship Adam with us to
whether students Tori Allen Angie Watson
Joe Brooke and Joe Wilbraham it will be
coming throughout the evening they are
watching from upstairs so they will be
down at the right time so we've got to
move on to item number two which is
disclosure of interests have we got any
disclosures I can catch the bonds I
should be going about aging [ __ ] mr.
chairman how much catch some else thanks
mr. chairman
item 3 will not house little kind I'll
be stepping off the panel here as it's
in my award I'll be speaking later
I know footer
Vonn to item number three which is
application number 17 for / 0 1 4 3 6 r
am which is won't house little cotton
Warrick and I've got to pass on to David
David Jeffrey who's presenting this
force Thank You chair as you correctly
note this is application 17 / 0 1 4 3 6
/ REM this is site in little Kyneton to
the south of little current oh sorry
to the south of little current in itself
and to the west of tie so road the
application is a reserved matters
proposal relating to the approval under
1503 oh 6 4 out which is a grant of
permission for nine dwellings with
access oft ISO Road this plan shows the
position of the silent marked with the
black dot relative to the settlements of
Kyneton little Kyneton others Marston
this plan shows the site bounded in red
adjacent to the conservation area of
little countin listed buildings are
marked in red here the green hatched
line which crosses the site is the route
of a public footpath this is the former
route shown it's actually now been
rerouted following the outline approval
the site comprises an empty paddock
which is bounded on three sides by
hedgerows and between Tysoe road and the
application site it's particularly a
heavy hedgerow the site itself is is
flat grassland this is an excerpt from
the kind and neighborhood development
plan showing that the site is allocated
for housing purposes it's included as
part of the wider site as you'll see
which extends west and north of the
application site around walnut house
which is the area marked in labelled the
green these images show the point on
Tysoe Road where access will be taken
onto the site on this image you're
looking at this hedge on the right where
access will be put through there and on
this image you're looking on the left
here access into the field just
emphasizes the points it's an extremely
heavy hedge there these images show a
view from within the site looking north
towards who owned that house and then
scrolling across into the area of the
overall allocation where the goal posts
are is not part of the site at the
moment the area will be subject to the
later application which we are in
receipt of but will not be attending
this committee again within the site
this time looking to the south towards
the neighboring property the thickness
of the hedge boundary trees can be seen
there on the other side of those bushes
is Tysoe Road but it cannot be seen from
within the site at the moment
I just moved to a video shows again from
within the site has changed a little bit
this videos taken today and the earlier
photos shown in summer months so within
the center of the site here looking but
towards the neighboring farm building
looking into the neighboring site now
and the location of the footpath enters
the site and then back towards the trees
and hedges towards Tysoe Road a second
video shows the site from the point
where the footpath enters it again
looking towards Tysoe Road very similar
as before the neighboring farm building
the approximate line of the footpath is
where the grass is improved by being
lawn mowed and then back towards Walnut
house
moving on to the proposals the landscape
that's why this plan shows the proposed
layout nine dwellings are arranged
around a cul-de-sac which curves into
the site two properties
towards the front of the site are
proposed to be in that style properties
across the site are a mix of styles and
architectural features and include
different types of materials including
red brick stone and white render these
landscaping proposals do show a
requirement in the north of the site to
remove some trees these would be
counterbalanced by additional planting
along the route of the footpath here
quite fine there the neighboring
farmhouse Hall farmhouse haven't raised
objection to the proposal there came to
see the details of boundary treatments
being a fence of around six foot in
their view would be acceptable it's
notable that the the plot that's closest
to them has a blank gable facing onto
their property these street scene
elevations show the mixed architectural
styles proposed the applicants aim has
been to complement the existing
vernacular in little Kyneton and in
current in itself as I say to include a
mix of brick render and of stone the
height of these three-story property see
there is around nine meters
so around nine meters to the chimney
that has been revised to try and make it
more bucolic more villagey in style
other elevations within the site itself
showing the thatched properties and some
buff materials in the walls but
predominantly red brick and render the
end of the presentation chair there are
a couple of updates within the update
sheet which I'll draw your attention to
a correction on page 8 where wrongly
referred to this as a steep site it is
flat the county authority have received
the plan which they were seeking then
have subsequently removed their
objection I would also mention further
to my comments in the agenda report
relating to financial contributions new
correspondents from the development
enabling officer now recognizes that the
preferred amount of contribution would
be around two hundred and forty nine
thousand and eight pounds this is still
amount that we are considering together
with an independent viability consultant
and the applicant so the officers
recommendation has slightly changed
given highways position officers
recommend that reserve matters be
granted subject to the completion of a
legal agreement which secures a
financial contribution to affordable
housing in accordance with the outcomes
of that independent viability consultant
and with regard to the additional
condition which is within the update
report thank you move on now to our
first speaker which is catch the david
Gosling from Canton Parish Council
hello cancel Gaza how are you good
you've got three minutes you know this
girl right
show your wall first time would you like
a 30 seconds warning
counselors the full sight in little
Canton this full sight of live
accountant is identified as a policy
development site in the neighborhood
plan and suitable as suitable for
approximately ten dwellings now we can't
find a dictionary definition to
determine what numerical variation would
constitute approximately but we envisage
plus and minus 10% therefore shouldn't
come as a surprise to you that the
outline application for nine houses were
supported that an application was
approved containing the following
wording for design constraints based on
the traditional vernacular and a row of
traditional roadside cottages matching
those found on the opposite side of the
road beyond the green this reserved
matters application shows a considerable
departure from these outlined proposals
we've not had the benefit of
face-to-face discussions with the
developer to resolve our concerns
instead having to work through the
planning officer to put forward our
remaining objections the first being
design since one person's opinion of
good design can be as different as the
next persons we turned to a qualified
and reliable architect to give his
opinion of whether these proposals could
truly be claimed to be based on the
traditional vernacular while still
others found the design of plots four
and five to be totally out of character
and more suited to suburbia with their
integral term garages they are not
visible from the road plot 3 on the
other hand his position to dominate the
site physically and is highly visible we
knowledge that the developer has made
some minor changes moving from bread
brick to stone and we would ask that if
you approve this application the stone
should be conditioned to be real local
stone and not reconstituted imitation
but the scale of this single dwelling is
not in keeping with anything in the
immediate vicinity even if you widen the
search area to include the whole of
count'em there are no detached
two-and-a-half storey houses and we
therefore suggest that this specific
house design does not comply with the
policy D 1 of the neighborhood plan
which state development in rural areas
should be well designed and inclusive in
keeping and scale with its location in
the planning officers report you will
have read that he says these are large
dwellings for little accountant by
definition there
or not in keeping with the scale of the
location our other concern is associated
with landscaping planning officer in the
report could not have stated it more
clearly there would be a modest amount
of residual harm to the landscape
arising from this development after
mitigation unfortunately this mitigation
is not defined adequately not specified
in conditions and despite our heritage
architect offering recommendations we
will remain with define 30 seconds 30
it's a real shame that we were not able
to resolve these difficulties without it
needing to come before this committee
but as you will realize we do not see
our neighborhood plan is merely a way of
controlling the scale and location
development I ask you to reject the
application in its current form failing
as it does to meet policies D 1 D 2 and
policy e 6 on trees and hedgerows thank
you I'm spot on if we got any questions
councillor Ghazi case the bars in the
paperwork about that chimneys spanking
is that been resolved I think you
probably referred to where the architect
may want you to make sure that it wasn't
the guttering as well as fashion yes to
the finish of the houses are you
satisfied with the one and for the two
outside of the entrance that they are
not going to be of local stone because
you've got other houses in the vicinity
that are of hauntin stone I know there
are some brick ones but it seems that
the appear to lose that Horton stone
look that you have further around the
corner coming up to the main road
I think that we tried to be reasonable
and realistic the two at the entrance on
either side the two that ones are the
ones that I believe it to be rendered
and there's plenty of evidence of
rendered finish in Kyneton and little
coins and non properties I'm finding
evidence of fetched properties of that
size is is difficult but again as I as
I've said when it comes to what is
design what is acceptable design it gets
a little bit difficult which is why we
asked ara
our architect who contributed to
variable our plan to look specifically
at this and his comments very much come
down to this particular mock Georgian
and affect the children house story that
I noticed David said dine meters I
thought at one point unless that's been
resolved revised it was going to be over
to ten metres to reach height he
canceled Gaza we haven't got any
objectives and our next speaker will be
mr. Warren Jones three minutes mr. Jones
felt like a warning in 30 seconds and if
you could stay there for any questions
afterwards yes please thank you okay
well my name's 1 Jones I am a
shareholder and director of natural
homes which is the developer and
applicant for this scheme in this will
kind - I'm aware of the this forum is
not one for me to reiterate what's in
the encounters report or amplify the
counters report in any way shape or form
I assure you I'm not here to do that and
I am here this evening
twofold really is to introduce myself
and I think that's the correct and right
thing to do and also just to give you a
very brief update as to where we've got
to from when we exchanged on this
contracts of nearly 12 months ago and
how we've got to the designs of where we
are it will be brief as whenever the
lists of the time but we exchange
contracts back in December last year and
we actually completed on the land in
April
back in December later we employed local
architecture than a lot of rule schemes
before giant use of ATO architecture and
we challenged James
firstly with to get his head round in
detail the outline application because
we were not party to the outline
application so first thing was what has
been granted in terms of shape size and
layout and then go and have a look at
the surrounding area look at the design
and access statement which shows that
roofs which shows Georgian properties
wanting kind to you know and they can be
seen in the design and access statement
and it was really our challenge to him
was please keep it within the
surroundings of the local area you know
make sure it sees of the highest quality
because that is what little coins and
deserves and that is where really we
started from we've introduced to
thatched-roof cottages at the entrance
of the development really with a view
keeping the the bulkhead for a long time
so Road as well if you're driving past
there the view here is to only see the
teeth thatched roofs and as you driving
past because we're keeping the head
Toronto solid well as I'm an application
that was to come out but that's very
valuable to us and everybody else the
existing footpath to be diverting
there's an additional tree belt to go
along the western boundary there as well
again which is very important to us as
well the Georgian property taken on
board the parish councils comments which
I think were correct in terms of the red
brick and we've taken those on board and
change those to the Buffs
stonework which will be in full
accordance with Rob Henry's property
next door or as we're trying to match
that to keep it in in keeping with
little content there is if you overlay
the act like 30 seconds okay overlay the
outline application with the reserve my
we are not too far away from what was
granted at outline we're here to
increase and enhance Azure content as a
whole with the highest quality of
property that we that we can deliver and
we're here to work with you certainly
not against you so there is the issue of
the viability that once that number is
agreed then good evening I just wonder
whether you can explain particularly as
you obviously acquired the site
following it's being granted outline
permission is there a particular reason
why I decided not to share your initial
thoughts and designs with the Parish
Council and secondly have you are you
familiar with the Contin neighborhood
plan okay
the there was no particular reason that
in hindsight is certainly one that we
wish we've done and we won't be doing
going forward should we have any other
developments in rural areas and they had
I agree with I can see that going fire
david jeffries is not ideal in these
scenarios and a lot of these could have
been resolved a lot sooner so that I can
only apologize and I'll take that as a
learning curve and all certainly be in
contacting parish councillors going
forward and quite happy to go do it
going forward on this scheme as well yes
I am I've been dealing with Rob handling
a lot of detail in that one because I
know Rob has split the sciences into one
and two and we know the other areas in
the in the in little contem that are
allocated within the neighbourhood plan
and I suppose really taken his lead but
in hindsight maybe taking meeting people
such as the parish and the local those
probably the best thing to do
that's the building what sort of car
parking spaces have you allowed on the
site they're all driveways and garages
each each each plot has a garage and a
drive like so I think it's it's - some
of them Sonic is there a plan that shows
it David you can see if you go around
from plot one around the development you
can see that there's a garage double
garret that's a double garage for a
second plot yeah keep going
another double garage there there's
integral garages for those two plots and
then those two plots they have the
courage that's it there and then again
that courage for that to eat that yes
yes sorry yeah it's it's a single garage
but with two parking spaces on the drive
in front of it I'm gonna say I think
we're we're happy with that I think we'd
rather for response and from my point of
view I think it was a big issue I'm sure
the parish council would have raised
that as well and as part of the
objections that I think we've answered
that quite well but of of the further
questions
cancel emails please could you just
reach that when I force why you're not
pleased oh sit down oh good we like to
see your best for our cats and I was in
five minutes
you know the drill one thank you to
chairman and good evening committee
committee members firstly this
application behind dwellings is contrary
to the kind to neighborhood development
plan due to this proposal being out of
character with little kind 'some yes we
do have a small thatched cottage but
certainly do not have three-story
residential buildings in little kinds
and and we certainly have no children
properties in the area of little kinds
in which plot number three shows the
report says that the 2.5 story Georgian
s property on plot 3 does not have an
immediate comparator in the village the
report also says that the nine
properties are large and in particular
two three and four and five but says
they sit comfortably within their plots
I feel this is a contradiction the
report also says the site will be behind
a hedge and therefore pose no harm the
houses will still be their hedge or no
hedge and I failed to see that the
defect that developed the developer has
drawn on the vernacular found in both
Clinton and little kinds and when
designing this development repeating his
arms of poor design from anywhere in the
neighborhood plan area which may have
arisen from a time when planning
controls were neither as strong or as or
as or well managed as they are today so
to justify the style of these proposed
dwellings in little kinds and in my view
is not acceptable block three four and
five show on the plans they are
oversized inappropriate and should be
redesigned to reduce their scale and
height district I didn't have
predominantly two-story cottages and
houses and therefore I feel that the
proposed houses
are far too high and large to fit in
with the local area they do not suit the
street scene in this part of little
kinds land which is at a gateway to the
village
I feel the developer has a duty to
embrace and enhance not detract from the
local character of the area and in it
and in this case the developer has a
great opportunity to make this site a
centerpiece of excellence all the way
through the report it highlights the
size of these houses and at the same
time try to permit it by saying no harm
is being done I wonder how many of you
have stood on the edge of agree village
green and not to cross at the proposed
site and conclude there will be no harm
and remember that boundary for the
conservation area runs right along the
by hand boundary of this site
despite the elapse of 16 months since
the committee approved the outline the
application you are now asked to approve
the reserved matters application which
until 2 days ago had an objection from
Warwickshire County Council concerning
pedestrian links and continue with one
from the Parish Council which has both
which has been asking for a clearer
definition of landscaping
I suggest that both of these should have
been satisfactorily resolved before
bringing this application before you
commit see these houses are outer
carriage to the local area and in my
opinion should be redesigned the
application I consider to be incomplete
I are not to grant consent to this
application the grounds are non
compliance of the neighbourhood plan
policies D 1 D 6 na u6 thank you very
much
catalyst of deaths and just I mean
obviously I think your if you were
looting their to quality of design but
is it just simply in the context because
looking at those houses would you agree
that they are good quality but in a
perhaps a different location is that
what your your thrust
I'm sure the quality is good but they
keep saying in my submission they're
totally out of character there are no
Georgian buildings in anywhere a little
kinder I think if you go into Clinton
itself you'd be for a hard push I'm a
little add more time is a toward you
Georgian desk but that is a you know a
long way from little kinds but it is
just the design and the the two point
five story building and I mean to walk
in and drive it and look at that I say
it just does not fit in quality I'm sure
I'm sure they make very nice houses and
I say we do have one fat cottage in
little Clinton so it runs off from that
but it's just the design thank you okay
the bonds what I was going to say really
was that in any village we get a mix of
properties because that's how they're
developed to me this looks like quite a
good mix they're not all the same it's
not urbanized you're complaining just
about a three-story building no I'm
complaining about the the they're quite
large and high and keep sorry to
reiterate it is just they're completely
out of character with with that part of
little Clinton and if you look around
the round little kind it's full of
houses that date back to the Battle of
Edgehill and before that
I the the to go back to my question
about the two houses you come into the
village which are the thatched ones
which I understand your comment because
there there is it only one thatched a
property in little Kyneton and that's
right on the on the junction the the use
of horns and stone I would have thought
would benefit and be very useful within
the village ambience I don't know what
your feelings are on that I'm sure
you're right I do agree with that to try
and keep all the houses yeah looking
pretty well I know we I know it's
impossible to to let's have exactly the
same so okay one state wouldn't hasn't
been identified as an issue by what the
post cats or the objectives but right
thank you very much Thank You mr.
chairman clarification got some
clarification points for the officer
thank you David and obviously there's
the concern here about the character in
this particular case now I think that is
my the way I get this on Caesarea the
actual the developments of the buildings
themselves but where it is in the
location so it comes down to the
neighborhood development plan in your
company or opinion does it comply with
that the local never plan are we happy
with that aspect they didn't turn in
your view please yeah happy happy to
pick up on on both of those points the
the Neighborhood Development Plan which
is is new and these parts of the
development plans to sits alongside our
core strategy the policies in there do
carry full weight the design policy
which is policy d1 reads that all
development in rural areas should be
well designed and inclusive in keeping
and scale with its location and
sensitive to the
to the countryside and local
distinctiveness developments that do not
demonstrate high standards of design
will be resisted so in that sense the
wording here is very similar to our own
policy in the core strategy cs9 on
design in that it is it does not
stipulate specifically that there shall
be no new types or characters of
buildings albeit that they should be
well designed and they must be sensitive
to the character of the location in
assessing this proposal what was in my
mind in particular was the depth of this
hedge here which will be largely
retained as you saw from previous slides
in terms of weather where the location
of the access will be you're looking at
something where there is an immediate
neighbors to this proposal except that
the property which is Georgian s chi
thing has been described on plot three
is two and a half stories it's three
stories is that style of property which
is intended to be architectural II
imposing I suppose you do see these
types of properties within countryside
areas and I think I described in my
report that they are you know singular
properties you don't see them in groups
you don't see multiples of them in in in
rows very often and and that is a matter
of planning judgment for counselors to
take whether they think that that's
appropriate for this location I do
perhaps just have a couple of additional
slides which might be helpful this is a
close-up of the neighboring property
on the side sorry sorry this is the the
frontage of the property
further down Tysoe Road Hall farmhouse
as you can see that there's an open
frontage there on to that property it's
design is is rural red brick it is quite
a substantial property in in many
regards I think that the open view onto
this property which will be before this
development on the entrance into little
Kyneton really means that this probably
will set the set the character of little
kind turn in terms of what people will
appreciate as they're coming down Tysoe
road more than the probe proposed
development because of the retention of
the hedge the property we were just
looking at there it's this one here it
appears to be but I can't confirm that
categorically the point made about this
views into the site being terminated by
this property that that is a fair point
I think the intention of the design is
that a view into this site should be
terminated by a quality building and
fundamentally that's considered good
design in most instances overall I was
content that this is a high quality
scheme Thank You chairman David I just
wonder where they dig going back to the
two and a half story property would it
be normal as part of your site visits
obviously little Kyneton is very much
very different in total character
to Kyneton would it be normal where
you're coming into a village or looking
at a new site that is a complete
conservation area that you will conduct
a spit of a survey on the the number of
stories of other buildings in that
particular location because obviously
Kyneton is a little bit is he's a main
rural center and has got a lot of new
development so you would you could
expect to see something like that in
paintin as a main rural center but
little Kyneton is really a little hamlet
that sits just outside kind turn so just
be helpful I just find it helpful if you
could just explain coming back to the my
big question mark on this two-and-a-half
storey building yeah in terms of process
I think it's reasonable to point out
that I was the case officer for the
original outline application which came
in in 2015 so have been visiting this
site and sites nearby for the last
couple of years certainly it's a matter
of planning judgment you know the where
there a new introduction is an
acceptable thing or not it clearly is
not something which exists in little
Kyneton at the moment that is not
necessarily an outright reason for
refusal we have to consider on balance
whether the proposal is acceptable in
design terms even though it may
introduce something new
a further slide I could show as well in
in relation to these comments this is
sorry this is the original outline plan
which was considered and approved as as
you see it takes in a very similar
pattern of development and the size of
the properties in plan form equivalent a
question to do with the affordable
housing contribution just clarify that
time but I'll see the figure mentioned
in the report was two hundred and ninety
four thousand and the applicant had
offered a lower figure five hundred and
forty-three
you said that was go up to two hundred
and forty nine thousand or the original
correspondence which we received from
development enabling officer suggested
two hundred ninety four thousand pounds
would be appropriate that has been
amended following review of the new
methodology for calculating off-site
contributions his position now is that a
contribution of two hundred and forty
nine thousand and eight pounds would be
appropriate in this circumstance the
applicant at the outset of the proposal
said that there would be concerned with
amount or in that order and offered a
hundred and forty three thousand two
hundred four we considered that was not
appropriate we saw no reason to accept
that without independent viability
consultant scrutinizing the details the
applicant has agreed to that process so
the recommendation has now reflected
that so we've agreed that an independent
viability consultant will confirm what
is the appropriate contribution
affordable for this scheme and that
would be secured by
the natural and taking section 106 Hamza
flying everywhere that which gets cancer
filled in first and I'll come back to
you classify with regards to the
reserved matters if this is to go ahead
are you making sure there is no parking
along the roadside all parking of
contractors and vehicles will be on site
and the outline permission is granted
subject to the imposition of a
construction management plan it
certainly would be intended to achieve
that part of that would be opening the
site access up first before further
development occurred and then in
securing areas for parking or loading
site contractors and so on
visiting the sites and staying on the
site rather than on the road that would
certainly be the aim the poem
yes it's regarding the affordable
housing is it is the reason for the
off-site the off-site contribution
because there is no local need for
affordable housing in the area
no the core strategy policy allows for
developments under 11 dwellings to make
financial contribution rather than to be
providing it on-site the requirement for
a financial contribution in this
instance arises because although there
are fewer than 10 dwellings they still
amount to more than a thousand square
meters of floor space so there is a
contribution required it doesn't have to
be delivered on site according to our
policies an off-site contribution is
policy compliant cargo just a brief one
was mentioned about the brick of the I'm
going to use the word pseudo Georgian
because it's not really a Georgian
building
however they were talking about the the
the brick and asking for it to be Stern
as opposed to the reconstituted stone is
that something that could be put into
conditions or material section the short
answer is yes the applicants detail says
that it will be a buff stone
it's neither confirm nor deny that it
will be a natural product but if members
see that to be a necessary requirement
it certainly would be an acceptable
condition counts of holding you two
questions one is having just had a
problem in a neighboring village where
the word stone was used and the
interpretation of that stone was
reconstituted stone I think that we've
got to identify that it's going to be
proper on stone or local stone rather
than reconstituted stone and the second
one is will the one if the 106 is not
the sign signed before
SILS come in will sills take precedent
or and can that money be ring-fenced for
the village the first point is is the
easier one yes we can condition it so
that we receive a material sample the
process that we follow as officers in
regard to stone samples now is that we
confer with parish councils before
discharging permission for stone to be
introduced to rural locations so the
Parish Council the ward member would
certainly be able to scrutinize the
proposed stone detail and if it was an
unacceptable reconstituted or a strange
natural stone that wasn't going to be
acceptable there would be opportunity to
decline to accept it
in terms of SIL yeah in terms of self if
I believe SIL is due to be adopted early
in the new year if the application
hasn't been decided so no decision has
been made no section 106 sign then this
application will then be subject to self
as it would come in as soon as the as
SIL is adopted
so for any live applications it would be
covered by self I think probably because
as a corollary to that it's fair to say
that if we got to the point of receiving
an independent viability report which
identified an amount we would expect
that process to signing a legal
agreement to be quite smooth if it
turned out not to be smooth the
applicant sort further negotiates I
think the likelihood is that we would
seek authority to refuse the application
on those grounds under delegated powers
okay cats on there debated in that hard
legal officer so he was said I'm not too
sure whether foot of the housing is
actually subject to sale so I'll have to
actually check that I believe it's
subject to a section 106 and would stay
contribution and the other part to
councilor Feldman's question is if you
want to ring-fence it to the village
safer three years like Thai so then you
can do so sorry a bit of collective
effort oh yes maces comments reminded me
yes
he's entirely correct there would still
be a section 106 requirement if SIL was
in place for affordable housing
contribution though it would be at a
modestly reduced amount because they
would also be sealed to pay right that's
lots of clarification there and I think
we've they've done very well we just
move on to the debate now if we who
would like to start on this barns thank
you very much
it looks to me like a bit of a village
which is what it's supposed to be in the
respect of you know villages are all
different types of houses whether it is
or isn't to that area I think the
important thing is that has been spoken
that we do use proper stone also what
we'd want to make sure that the Thatcher
is not read but as far as I can see yeah
I appreciate where the parish council on
the ward members are coming from if it
was in my patch I'd be quite happy with
it because as far as I'm concerned it
represents a different type of houses
which what a village is and the entrance
of thatch I think to me is we've got one
of the shot array and they've looked
exceedingly well they have to have that
a lot better than one will be expected
so I appreciate whether you're coming
from whether it suits Canton I don't
know but I'm not unhappy with it in my
village
thank you sure um
I'm not coming from the same perspective
as councillor bonds because I happen to
know a little kind and extremely well
I've got various concerns about the
proposal that is font first I think it's
the applicant has already admitted that
you know with Hine hindsight's good
science would have been a good idea to
speak to the parish council particularly
parish councils supported this
application as an outline so you know
they were they were friends in the camp
so it does seem very disappointing that
you know it was a good opportunity to
get the parish council on their side the
areas that I've got I have got a concern
about the design
I've got a concern about the turnoff
story property little Kyneton is not the
same as countin it is a hamlet and in
fact that site is at a very prominent
location as you're coming into approach
little Kyneton it's right next door to
the conservation area so I therefore
I've I've got concerns about the
character of the development on the
adjacent conservation area I think we
wouldn't be here discussing it as it war
as it is this evening if the applicant
to take the time to go and talk to the
parish council and say look this is what
we're planning on doing you know we we
wouldn't be having these discussions and
and I do think it's it's a great chain
on that so I've got real concerns about
the design I shall wait and see what
other people say but I'm emerging in the
opposite direction to the officers
recommendation I agree entirely with all
councillor Paris been saying because
little tighter he's got an open aspect
around the green the pond little Carlton
sorry little kinder sorry old age and
it's a it's got that lovely open expanse
this is very much tied in and it's very
much out of keeping in my view Kyneton
should be and it is a pity that it
wasn't discussed with the parish and to
that end I'm against it the cargo tricky
one
on the one hand I have to admit I think
a lot of community to be very pleased to
have a development like this because I I
do feel that they've got that little
extra modeling produced a go quality
design scheme and I suppose it just
comes down to where it is in the context
of the of the location and that's a bit
of a problem because obviously there's a
there's an area that have been granted
out my own planning permission and I do
wonder what the community would have
wanted given a free hand for example to
design it and there's a tricky one I
think there's something about cottages
well people don't want cottages they
want houses we are looking in small
rural communities to develop trying to
provide housing so that people can stay
in the areas now I do appreciate these
are going to be quality housing but even
so it's still trying to retain
communities and the cohesion and stuff
like I feel that it's well shell
children from the road it's not going to
be dominant like the house previous to
it which I find is we don't have an open
context to it is horrible really I was
both a big flat fronted building which
is looks fairly new from the photographs
I can't comment on that but again that's
that's a strained want to have got plane
permission in the first place so in
given the the concerns of the the parish
now I be honest to say III I think
perhaps council bars and I are agreeing
but that's because you live in a
different area I don't know but I feel
that this is actually a good quality
scheme and I'm in support of it catch
the Brian
it's very balanced application this one
I'm happy with the application actually
all the emphasis seems to have been on
number three I'm though much said about
the other is the part from the such ones
are good I'll be supporting the
application I'll keep it brief things I
did say I would says the stone issue if
this committee is minded then that I
feel that should be a condition that
regard the the material selection if we
will need to make sure the conditions
are the type of stone before then there
with the planner that's essential as
much as the material
yong-seok not that condition if we
minded to to agree I think the other
issue if we were minded to agree would
be the the viability of the affordable
housing obviously that's going to an
independent person the judicata so we
need to make sure that is covered
properly and I think mr. Nash might have
another point about designated or fired
he'll not Alba chairman it's probably
easier from Justin sir make sure the
actual chair of the committee signs off
the viability payment or one of the
pavement is is confirmed
obviously we seem to be quite a bit I'll
just tell you where I am at the moment I
can see there are concerns from the
parish council which could have perhaps
been addressed projects coming to
committee or prevent it even commented
committee which i think is quite
disappointing it's a learning point for
the applicant I'm not sure about the
conservation area impact that scares the
perry mentioned and it doesn't seem to
feature strongly in the papers so i'm
not sure how much white that would had
add onto this points from this side of
the room the left-hand side are in two
more left
indicated that they were supporting it
was well shielded from the road and the
bigger property which I believe was
called the farmhouse or something
similar and yeah I'm quite finely
balanced on this but I would be be
willing to support the officers
recommendation on this one
and again if we would mourn you to vote
on this I think would have to discuss
the conditions and particularly
ring-fencing of the affordable housing
contribution to its current and parish
council and the party of cotton or
cotton parts council so I'm happy to
propose based on those conditions the
106 contribution bring fast the
independent summary which will be
delegated on the choice of materials and
I do wonder whether the Chairman
shouldn't also be part of that selection
process so happy to go to live out we've
had a proposed on a second all those in
favor of improving the application as
proposed by council cargo with
conditions
one two three four chairman I'm those
against to chairman
sorry about and we move on to item
number four which is application 17 0 17
/ 0 1 0 77 REM LUN to the south of a 45
south on road Knutson on the hill
presenting officer yes David minion ship
thank you
yeah no problem cuts the darkness over
there Thank you very
I just like to declare an interest in
application 174 slash zero one nine six
eight ful halfway house it's within my
ward and obviously speaking of
supportive parish council thank you
thank you for making the effort and
while don't forget in here thank you
yeah thank you Jim
and so the application site is located
denoted by the black dots located on the
con the northern fringe of the village
Knutson on the hill
it forms roughly the northern half of
what is currently an open field you can
see that the more built-up area of the
the village extends to the east there so
it's currently an open field was granted
outline planning permission in 2015 for
for dwellings with all matters reserved
including access so the application we
have before us now is for the reserved
matters the site slopes towards the
south it's fairly steep so it's higher
at the South than it is at the north
where it meets the level of the public
highway so that posed a couple of design
problems for the applicant there is
quite a large number of existing trees
along the northern boundary that's
shared in the public highway at side of
the road as well as mature trees lining
the western and eastern site boundaries
and I've denoted there there's a cops of
trees as proposed to be removed to allow
for a subs pond here's the proposed site
layout just four detached dwellings with
the access located broadly centrally
within the site and the field that you
saw in the last photo would be split in
half so the northern section would
become residential land whilst the
southern section would remain
effectively as agricultural or open land
and this is the proposed landscaping
scheme its flipped north to south from
the last slides Asylum Road is now
extending across the bottom of the
screen here
so you can see that a lot of the
existing trees are proposed to be
retained I think there's one tree
proposed to be removed to allow for the
creation of the access but a number of
new trees and specimen shrubs are
proposed to be planted including an area
around this I suppose wall referred to
as an island here to the rear of the
access in this this sausage-shaped thing
in the bottom is a suds pond so a
sustainable urban drainage system pond
for the surface water and that would be
planted with native grasses and some
specimen shrubs and this is an extract
from the section 2 7 8 work plan showing
the site access the outline planning
permission actually contained a number
of I suppose directive conditions that
specified certain requirements that the
access would have to meet such as the
width provision of a pedestrian foot way
and provision of a pedestrian crossing
as well as issues relating to the
gradient of the access and drainage
around the access point the section 2 7
8 works has actually they've actually
been agreed by County Council now so in
terms of compliance with the outline
permission officers are satisfied that
the access is designed as effectively it
should be and this is plot one the
proposed elevations for plot 1 you'll
know on the bottom here this sectional
drawing the sloping of the site so
diagonal line is the existing site
levels with the slightly darker line
showing the proposed levels so there's a
little bit of work to be done there and
this is the dwelling that is closest to
Westcott house which is the east of the
site
that's plot two so very similar in
design plot three plots two and three
early central dwellings plot four which
is within the western area closest to
the neighboring property at blue house
and next we have a proposed street scene
view it's hopefully it's easy to see on
the larger screens the top street scene
view is what was originally proposed and
there were some concerns raised over a
number of I suppose architectural
features that were were proposed and the
overall height fenestration layout of
the dwellings the bottom street scene is
what came out of those concerns and
discussions that followed over the
design and if i zoom in here this is
what we are now looking at as the
proposed street scene so a few drama
windows have been removed from plots two
and three garages have been quite
drastically reduced in size and setback
to reduce the overall scale and increase
the size of the gaps between the
dwellings and the fenestration layout is
better eaves and ridge heights are lower
as well than they were previously and
here are some photographs this is
showing the side of the road view of the
site so you can see there's quite a lot
of existing mature tree cover with some
additional tree planting proposed the
bottom photograph is broadly where the
site access is to be located these are
internal views within the site top one
is looking east towards Blue House which
you can't see the tree cover the bottom
image is looking west towards Westcott
house which is slightly visible but a
sufficient separate separation distance
away and also screened and this area
actually that's facing towards would be
the subs pond location the drainage pond
this is visibility from the approximate
access location the engineer highways
engineer confirmed
that they can achieve 120 meters in
either direction which the outline
permission actually stipulated with what
a requirement and these are the the
closest neighboring dwellings the top is
Westcott house and the bottom is blue
house which is a slightly more modern
dwelling possibly late mid to late 20th
century and that is the end of the
slides the application was brought to
committee due to a parish council
objection that related to an overly
urban design of the dwellings excessive
height of the dwellings compared to the
neighboring properties and concerns also
raised with regards to the pedestrian
crossing point and proposed drainage
details that they actually being dealt
with by a separate discharge of
conditions and the recommendation is to
approve subject to the conditions
recommended in the officer report and
there are no additional updates
[Music]
protection it would have been dealt with
them the delegated authorities it under
been to the objection we can't hear the
counter-argument the board members not
here I'll move the recommendation
chairman mr. Perry I'd like to support
cancer brains proposal a second case the
felony and crumb the plan there it looks
like there is a proposed proposal to
develop the background is that is that
the case
there yeah though there are these on the
landscaping plan there are these of
access roads shown and they've actually
been removed from the revised site
layout plan so that it was queried why
they were put in and and they're not
really big enough to provide any kind of
decent vehicular access to the rear land
I would be very surprised if an
application would come forward for
development of the the land to the rear
mainly because it's probably likely to
be considered to be open countryside so
it would just generally conflict with
the principle of development policies in
the core strategy I did I did directly
ask the applicant and they said no they
only put those accesses in because I
think the idea is that the two plots on
the side of the development would be
sold with the land to the rear so if
they wanted some kind of small paddock
or access to the land to maintain it
they could have it but these these
little access lanes that are showing
here they were actually taken off the
revised slightly out plan so that is
something we could possibly ask them to
do on the landscaping plan I'll be
honest it's my mistake that it's still
there and I haven't asked them to update
that capsule Ward and I can certainly
confirm it just slow extremely having
walked up quite here's slope still my
election campaign we've had a proposal
on a second s are more than happy to go
to the vote so all those in favor of the
proposal that's unanimous chairman this
committee resolves to grant application
17 / 0 1 0 some 7th REM thank you thank
you I'll move on to item number 5 which
is
17 / 0 0 9 6 1 if you are the homestead
Potter's line dance could change the
views of leung to go on and associated
with the handset together with the
construction of garage and garden store
presenting this thank you this
application was considered before
members at East area playing Committee
on the 13th of September must deferred
from member site visit so the context of
the application site could be better
understood the member site visit was
carried out this Monday the 23rd of
October in attendance was count to the
brain counts the fielding and offices
details of attendance were included on
the update sheet the proposal has not
changed in some members previously
considered the application and have been
no material changes on site the
application site lies to the northwest
of Dolly's got settlement as identified
by the blacktop on this plan this slide
identifies the application site outlined
in red the site lies adjacent to the
settlements conservation area which is
shown by the pink line to the east of
the application site which is just here
to the south of the site lies sundial
house which are grade 2 listed building
2 shown on this slide in red just here
public footpath s has one five eight
crosses the site traveling northwards as
shown by the green dashed line just here
this location public footpath s has 175
also crosses from east to west to the
north of the site plan information is
sought for the change of youth for
existing amenity land - garden land and
they were actually the detached
outbuilding both the which who proposed
to serve the homestead which a dwelling
located fees to the application site the
homestead also has an existing garage
and garden area revised plans have been
sought and forthcoming during the course
of the application in response to
concerns raised by counsel to third
party is in relation to the informal
turning area at the end of Potter's Lane
the amendments also include a revision
to the extent of the application
so just for clarity this plan to the
left of the slide has been superseded
and the extent of the application site
has now been reduced to this area here
so the area and blue is proposed to be
converted to garden land so change of
use and the siting the outbuilding has
been set back
compared to the previous plan this slide
shows a proposed outbuilding which
comprises of a garage in a garden store
the building is simple in design with
pit roof and limited fenestration the
height of the ridge of the proposed out
building is approximately 4.6 meters at
the highest point and the outbuilding
would measure approximately eight point
three meters at its widest point and
five point seven meters in depth at its
deepest point so the garret in the
garden store this slider is a photograph
of Potter's Lane looking northwards the
extent of the public highway finishes
approximately here just by the gates if
you can see them just to the right
beyond this point the road becomes a
private road this slide has a number of
photographs looking along part of lane
the top left image is looking southward
close to the gates which were identified
in the previous slide and shows a road
sorry where the widest section of the
roads are this photograph on the top
right is taken from the gate to the
right here looking northwards sundial
house is located to the right of this
image and to the left you can see the
gardens and parking areas associated the
dwellings to the left the rest of
Potter's lane
looking down to the bottom left to see
the application site at the north end of
Potter's Lane misses a gable here of
sundial house a grade 2 listed building
and the final image on this slide is
looking southwards down with the gardens
of the properties long part is lie on
this side here and sundial house on the
left of the image this slider is a
photograph of six Potter's Lane and the
area to the south of the application
site referred to as the informal turning
area within the officer report so this
is outside of the application sites
number six
Potter's lane here and their existing
parking this photograph is taken looking
northwards towards the application site
the application site extent is
approximately
here and extent across from this area
here over to this area here this is a
homestead in its existing garden area
and to the right-hand side of this image
as a public footpath which heads
northwards into open countryside this
slide shows a photograph looking across
the application site you can see here in
the background the outbuildings located
in the garden of six Potter's Lane this
photograph is taken looking southwards
down Potter's Lane number six is located
over here this is the application site
and we were on the public footpath
looking southwards this photograph was
taken from a public footpath to the
north of the application site the
homestead dwelling is just to the left
and the outbuildings a sixth part of
lane to the right here and this is the
application site and this is looking
back along the public footpath with the
application site on the right and the
homestead just here looking back down
from the other public footpath you can
see the homestead the application site
extent and number six Potter's lane to
the right of the image there are a
number of updates which have been
circulated on the update sheets the
recommendation is to grant planning
permission subject to the conditions and
notes outlined on page 35 of the
committee agenda thank you and I don't
know whether we can call him worse or
stop as well yeah if these are willing
to come forward for five minutes
chairman this has been a difficult
application to handle and as well as my
own concerns that have been concerns
from the parish council they did attend
on the previous meeting when the
application was deferred for the
particular site visit and I think in
some ways the diagrams are before us are
a little misleading but because it talks
about a superseded plan and a proposed
block plan now you should be considering
the proposals not what might have been
although what might have been is
certainly in the back of my mind where I
lodged my objections and then as a
result of that there have been
improvements the reason that I sustained
by objections was because the people
that lived at number six and perhaps
therein could point out where number six
is on that plan that's it there yes
effectively found themselves in a
bizarre situation as you will see from
the unadopted roads down to this
particular location they're very narrow
they were literally a concrete block
laid down when the council houses were
built in the 1930s and the number six
has that access across that road ever
since that time probably not with the
same residence but that's that's by the
by now we have a sad situation whereby
the people in the home state which is
clearly marked up there were sold by a
little bit housing the road out of the
front of number six and that somehow or
other marooned them almost such that
they were under the superseded plans
going to have to drive across their
neighbors garden to get into their own
front
five way and this was a bizarre
situation so consequently I'm pleased
with the improvements that have been
made but what I want to do is to ensure
that in planning terms that the
residents of number six have absolute
maximum rice I remember at the last time
I think it was councilor brain said this
isn't the planning matter but we all
know that if people have to rely on
litigation to actually get their rights
it becomes an impossible task an
expensive and impossible so I want us to
maximize the opportunities for the
residents of number six and number five
to retain the access across somebody
else's land which are now not being
asked to make to be garden and thank
goodness and that's that's vitally
important I think the concept of putting
the buildings back helps and the
reduction in the site area for the
application also helps but I can't
stress the importance of suddenly
someone finding the road outside they're
owned by orbit housing being sold to a
private residence and that private
resident were then actually making what
many of us observed were rather
difficult constraints on on the
residents who I feel should have
completely free access to their land and
the way that they've enjoyed it and the
people have enjoyed those properties for
about the last 80 years thank you very
much that was very concise and well
within your time sir
oh very impressed with that any any
questions for the warden and the council
fielding I really don't know actually
one of the residents is here tonight I
don't think the tenure of that proper
actually matters I don't know who owns
it whether it's it whether it's owned by
all be there whether it's privately
owned it could be either okay thank you
it's not a embody of it we've got the
council folio is supplementary sorry can
we not create some sort of restricted
covenant over it for the the legal side
that we were talking about all something
that nature
sorry
whatever this last time you know we'll
just clarify the situation would like to
add to this I think we'll have some
poetic license here we're stepping back
into property issues which I won't last
on that really as a committee you
shouldn't be doing this is a planning
committee and you step in beyond your
powers now the owners to the homestead
have confirmed that number six have
rights over that piece of road at the
top now to go into depth orbit owned one
three and five so when orbit we're
selling the land adjoining the homestead
they revived the sold its to number six
or to the homestead because eventually
when they sell all the houses on
Potter's Lane they don't want no access
road at all so they don't have to
maintain anything that's the issue there
but number six do have access right over
the turning circle that has been
confirmed by the lawyers of the
homestead thank you chairman that's the
first I've learned to that so I'm
encouraged any questions Thank You
counselor sight see a bit later on in
the agenda see a bit later on in the
agenda who will see me a little later
Sam move on to points of clarification
as the podium just a quick question what
is the finish of the garage is it in
keeping with the homestead material or
how you what is the finish the finish is
shown here so they're looking to have
tiles on the roof at boarding to the
smaller bharden store area here and then
brickwork to the garage I'm moving on to
the divide who's willing to stop cancer
Brian thank you one of the two people
who went to the side visits I think it's
appropriate that the cancer surgeon or
myself comment on this one
please I went on the site visit and to
see the amended plan to not include the
turning circle so that's not part of our
consideration at all tonight along
grateful to mr. Nashville clearly not
the civil matter we mentioned before
although I felt a little bit scolded by
the leader of the council tonight that
I've got it wrong I'm happy with the
application I think the designs right I
think we ought to protect it of you
becoming a residential property at any
stage but that's my own thoughts I'm
happy to support the application the
parry I was just going to add that it's
welcome to see that the the orientation
and the proposal on the application
situs has has taken on board our
comments at the last planning East
Committee and that there is room for
vehicles to number-6 to turn so I'll be
supporting this application don't you
cancel Mills yes mr. chairman yes I
didn't go on this site visit this week
but I have been on visit this some site
yeah again pleased to see the amendments
there and I just back up what counselor
brain and poyo said and will support
recommendations chair
next then can't slow down or cancel very
briefly yeah I did go to cite it though
he only found that I was subbing on the
Monday and I was unable to make the
visit then he thought what I'd had was
looking down that Lane you look into
open countryside and this is now going
to be in front of you however no one's
made any comments at all about that and
it's only 4.6 meters tall so I suppose
that sort of mitigates out but it has
been mentioned other previous prebiotic
air planning applications their lack of
openness and it is a beautiful view out
of the back of that property however I
soon began to like oh and what
councillor Paris that it was great to
see that our comments were listened to
and the plans have been adapted
accordingly so I'll be supporting the
officers recommendation building I'd
like to second councillor brains
proposal on it actually proposed it but
I will if you want thank you Karen and
help you to confirm that and any any
conditions conditions did mention
condition we have asked for samples of
materials and also in relation to
accounts of feelings point in terms of
restricting it to ancillary to the
homestead is a condition that's proposed
very much we've kind of proposed on the
second day so could go to the back
please
all those in favor ask unanimous
chairman Thank You counsel cattle
committee resolves to approve
application grant application 17 / 0 0 9
6 1 fu out and we're moving swiftly on
to item number 6 on the agenda
yeah which is application 17 / 0 1 9 6 8
/ if you are halfway house 67 ships in
Road older Minister proposed for the
first floor site and two-story rear
extension presenting officer is Andrew
Watson so just give him a few moments to
thank you said this application was
deferred at the Committee on velocity to
East Committee remembers to view the
site clarity the cybers was carried out
on Monday there was three members on
site and we did have a look round twelve
people so I'd equate local and said it
was also noted that now how to next door
but you'll see on the slide is now under
construction so that's first slide there
so they've got the black spot which
marks the pitiful position of the site
and so now what it marked in red if
you've seen from the south there's a bit
of a vague that's an open grassy area
this similar side to the other side of
the junction and their buildings 18 red
hollister buildings and we've got snow a
photograph of the site and the site is
just decided the property is where the
ground floor extension cord was is
located and then we've got two plans
showing the sites location of top one
and pred also at the site plan change
because the the site plan was wrong that
is to correct in a position now of the
garden boundary on the top right hand
corner the plan on the bottom side is
there is a large view of the site
showing the extension that's proposed
then we'll come to the drawings of the
site across the top you've got the
existing property as you can see where
the flat single-story is the extension
is now we're gonna cook
probably this two-story if sex that is
to go from the Abu Dhabi first floor
beside the ground floor to create the
first floor and extend from the rear of
the property of three meters into the
garden and we've got the plans on this
plan now you can see on the plans on the
right on the left you got the what is
now the defined as the building which is
under comes now under construction and
the gap between the two properties is
one meter now looking at spoilt
aggression within the garden this is
before the house when the construction
was started and say that's the ground
floor extension aware the go people to
be enough asked me to distance drop from
the existing verge line of a grade or is
also to be taken out in the in the
proposals that's talking about side
elevation from within the garden the
window there will remain because it's
the only window that offers light into
the kitchen that's looking in the back
garden that's the house next door number
69
again that's in the garden of its
property that's the same again and that
one is looking at down the driveway at
number six line it's just that show that
there's only one window on the far
corner and there's nothing on the side
elevation oh I was talking about with
permission this shows the plans that
we've already approved the house next
door
some pajama on the left-hand side so
there's a metre gap to walkway down
between the two that got the front
garden the property will become its
parking area and in terms of the design
the property next door is no way that
the existing property which will be
literally I than the proposed extension
and in terms of that property there's no
windows on the
Eastern elevation will push him did
remove PD rights to put in window
there's no windows pro sorry on that
elevation but we have taken away PD
rights for extensions and roof
alterations and the property is about
after me to tell me to below the
existing property of that wall I stared
in the presentation so the date is that
we'll have them end at plan and the
recommend approval
three minutes short thanks very much
the parish council objects to this
application and made its representations
in the last Planning Committee meeting
on the 13th of September the parish
council is grateful to the councillors
who took the time to come under a site
visit on Monday as it's the belief of
the parish council that this application
is still an over development of the plot
when you consider the overall
development with it with the with with
the additional dwelling which was which
is in in the garden of the at the garden
of the property the core strategy state
the high density development and the
loss of garden are thought to be
unsuitable in certain locations and the
parish council believes the further
development of this plot is not in
keeping with it with the village I also
note from from the slide shown earlier
on that the proposed extension does not
in my opinion look as if it's
subservient to the main two at the main
house so therefore the parish council
maintains objected objection to this
application parish council we've had no
no contact at all with the applicant
very much
it's like I don't know five minutes and
would you like a warning at 30 seconds
yes it won't be that long okay I'm good
evening committee obviously I'm speaking
in support of the parish council I would
ask members to be aware that actually
the photos we've seen her out of date
because the building of the house next
door or in half of the applicants garden
is actually well underway and it changes
the dimensions completely when you stand
in the outlines of the proposed
extension and you have the the new
building happening as well it really is
a very very tight fit and I would concur
with what the Parish Council are also
stating that it feels very much like
herb development to the plot when you're
standing in the guidelines the extension
you're practically touching a new
property and any God to speak of
disappears so it feels like we're really
pinching the outskirts the plot I don't
believe the aerial photo is truly
reflective of the plot either and policy
cs9 calls for attractive sensitive and
distinctive designs and I really
questioned how this application meets
any of those requirements it's not
sensitive to the attached house there's
actually three houses involved here I
know we're really talking about the
extension but it's attached it's a
semi-detached house on an or an angle on
an L shape almost you've then got this
new extension happening and then you
have the new house alongside so I don't
believe it is sensitive there were
concerns raised by the podcast about CS
20 and I think it's worth your
consideration the parasha cancel they're
keen for homeowners to get the maximum
out of their potential their property to
remain in locality but it's really
concerning the scale of this extension
and given the design we do question
whether it is truly subservient to the
original house it's worth noting as well
that in the village there is a another
house which has consistently been
extended and now is leading to over the
development of the plot and I think
that's also causing them some concern
that this could become a pattern with an
order minister and their little bit
concerned about the consistency of
judgments regarding applications and
applications getting to the extent where
it does feel like over development to
the plot the applicant didn't engage the
parish council
I'm delayed any first the application
for this extension if it goes ahead will
change the street scene
it appears overbearing for the size the
plot its overshadowing it feels like
you've development and doesn't feel like
it's observant to the the main house and
perhaps it's want to reconsider on a
smaller scale and I thank you for your
time the applicant hadn't spoken to the
parish council did the applicant
actually speak to you know I'm from
harveyetta T neighbors to the property
actually contact you about this no
because the not not an attached property
and obviously the people in the new
property that that's in the garden of
this of the applicant so they're in
counts low Donal looking at at the plan
would you you're saying it's it's it's
over development from from your
perspective which supports what the
parish council say is there a particular
element of that extension that you feel
just goes a bit too far yes I think it's
the rear element of the extensions
they're not necessarily going up
although that will change the street
scene but it goes the way it goes i
accounts Lapera towards the river the
property it really does feel like you've
taken up every available meter of garden
or you know space of garden available
and very close to the new new building
so just coming back to that you wouldn't
have a problem if it just went up on in
its current footprint on that that one
side it's because it goes out back into
the garden that is your where your real
concern on the over developments for the
over development yes because that's
where you feel like you're really
pinching the boundaries of the plot and
for the fact you know the extension
going up that will change the street
scene which of course is a concern of
the parish council but my concern
theater development of the plot was on i
saw the size towards the rear of the
property
caro-kann move on to points of
clarification here's the cargo a right
subservience I noticed an in our room a
policy document about does it modify
your own home or whatever it is I
noticed on the sort of front view of it
it did step down correctly I notice it
doesn't step in the extension does not
step in why not yes he creates to set
doubt about alpha meter from the ridge
of the roof as a whole across all plane
from Tim bike I don't know why the
extension not stepped in and said I only
came into this rather late in the day
I'm afraid colleagues nor the report but
say normally to serve you do X you do
require setting from the top and on the
front of the back if you can get it but
in this case whether you can get to it
or not the ground floor being before
with the elevation I'm not sure
the the pity of it is that others didn't
go to the site visit because the number
one or the one property to the right of
this one I think it's not there there
are two numbers on there they even see
the the the to number the the two
buildings aren't they sort of
overdevelopment and they're rather on
top of each other particularly now
they're going to put the third one at
the house on the end of this building it
is going to be a very over developed
site is that not the case yes I suppose
they've got the house next door that's
under construction is being built on the
garden the front garden becomes a car
parking area as part of that scheme then
what you've got left at the back we've
got a very small triangle area
triangular area most of the guns being
built on and give up to this new
property properties or context I was
going to put this street view armed
attack on when I looked at the bit out
of more out of eight of these and trees
was in the way so it wouldn't really
show anything okay I've been property to
move on to the debate now he would like
to start the case right one of the
fortunate ones who went on the side
visit again and I'm disappointed that we
haven't gotten any up-to-date
photographs showing the construction
started as their house that's been given
permission which was the start of the
troubles in my opinion and glad had
nothing to do with it first of all the
new house to the left in the garden the
floor level is approximately six feet
lower than the property that we see in
the picture in front of us within the
planning officer would agree with
there is a difference but say when I was
looking at the plans there was they they
put this property at the zero then the
new property with a 4-1 but as you're
going down and say I'm the on that plan
is what you can't quite see it you have
got some retaining walls that run down
the side of the path to all the land up
because there is a difference of about
half a meter to a meter in places
rightly or wrongly the Builder told us
that had to put two meter foundations in
to hold the other foundation up so
that's the start loss of a minute II
space over the group of the parish
council and the ward member it leaves a
very small triangle at the back with the
extension I think you agree with that I
think it's overbearing and over the
development of the site it is very very
close than the cost of the garden levels
seem more imposing on the new property
than vice-versa
the design and layout for the street
scene is not good either and I say it's
a pity you didn't show some up-to-date
photographs it would have been great how
it's not sympathetic to the streets in
the tour so I was supporting application
unfortunate when I've been on site every
time of beam they've been billed as
materials materials in the way so I
couldn't really get any clear context
view of the site but I understand what
you're saying that house being there I
did try on a couple occasions but say it
was wet and it was muddy and thought it
was too late to do it on Friday okay
Andrew thank you for that one note
affair
kiss the car go over there okay back
working there thank you I do agree with
the council brain I did go to side again
because of busy I wasn't able to go on
the site visit and I'm concerns about
the subservience aspect I appreciate why
they've done it problem because the
existing
ian is obvious observing from the first
floor
however if they're going to for example
use that as the footings for the the
main extension then fine if it's not
then it should be subservient as well
neighboring amenity we talked about the
amenity in the garden but also now
having that double extension height a
shall we say a right next to the new
build I think will be overbearing and
over development of the site itself I
think it fails on the CS twenty five six
three and which says they should assure
it strikes an appropriate balance
protect the amenity of neighboring
residents character the locality and
taking all other material planning
considerations into account so I think
it fouls on that particular point to I
think we've also count the brains picked
up a few of the points I just don't
think it's suitable for a rural location
so I won't be supporting it the male's I
think it was chairman again I didn't go
on this site visit but I had it's this
way it's like first time around um yeah
I mean this is a free weekend again
council brain is really as over
development at this site and it does
certainly doesn't fit him or the
straightest thing it just just crammed
in so I won't unfortunately if be
supporting the obvious of recommendation
was chairman thank you that's the the
earlier plan shows a gate between the
two the old the new and the the one that
is part of the application that access I
presume is to the new house so there is
no access from the once this development
takes place to get round to the back of
the applicants the applicant building
it's just too over the top and I you
know I wish you'd been on site to see it
yeah been a vice that would have to be
some form of access so I think what the
flyover what you're saying cast
authority
I think we'll move on no ketchup Ari
just very briefly I wasn't able to go
onto the site due to other work
commitments but I just would like to
point out that okay whilst the existing
side part that has been extended can't
be step back because it's already there
the roof of the roofline doesn't step
down which is a condition of the
extending your home side of things and I
do feel that because it's part of a set
it's it's a semi-detached house it it
just is completely dominant to its
neighboring property so along with my
colleagues I'm going against the
officers recommendation on this one it
is a shame that the applicant isn't here
so we could have asked the applicant for
some more details which would have
potentially helped the debate in the
conversation I'm getting the flavor that
doesn't seem to be more support for this
application regarding loss of me and see
overbearing over the moment protecting
them how dominancy imposing design and
light not sympathetic to street scene so
it's quite a few points here are we
edging towards any proposal so cancer
Brian proposed
I'm happy with what you covered there
counselor and in effect
street scene I think then the main one
and design but then you know that the
the there's no subservience there in
terms of the extension and as you say
over development potentially overbearing
as well yeah loss of immunity is an
interesting one because obviously the
house that's there is or and being built
is already approved and the footprint of
what's proposed in terms of the
extension is quite modest in terms of
its take off the garden but we can we
can add that in it'll be quite a
encapsulating reason for refusal
I simply certain unanimous chairman
so what committee has agreed to refuse
resolved to refuse application 1701 nice
excite f you are
stubborn little pause while we get
sorted wasps work war upon a fighter
with pups over a small comfort break for
two minutes
Thanks
there's an alteration to existing rear
wing and creation of four parts
presenting officer is Joe Brooke thank
you Joe
Thank You chair I just realized the
agent is Jane Kaczmarek only done a plan
and applicator for me just for avoidance
of any date for transparency right
you're happy too thank you thank you
thank you
the application is 20 cheap Street in
ships on OnStar reference 17 four star
zero two two six zero for the
application sorry essentially located in
the market an electron star the premises
lie on sheep sheep Street which is one
of the main retail streets with in town
society there's two story building we
were shocked frontage the ground floor
and storage space above is a mid toast
building sitting amongst a row of of a
retail units situated at street level in
addition seat Street is located win the
ship's non-hostile Conservation Area and
form part of the built-up area system
the prose was for the Moloch Asian
modification is the existing a one
retail unit can poison a physical trace
into its appearance together internal
subdivision to great to smaller shop
units the application also seeks a one
on our story extensions that are real
the property together with the creation
of four flats of the upper floors of the
building in addition the building next
to the application so it is also a
listed grade two building as you can see
on this plan this is cheap stair along
here this is the application site this
is the car park access to the flats is
proposed to rear and this is via
Telegraph Street onto the additional car
park that shot will be accessed from
seat Street towards the front this is an
aerial view of the site it shows that
the built up form around the sound an
area in the different ways that is built
and there how it extends I would the
smaller listed building is just there
number 22 shapes tree as you can see
that as a small unit
the site itself expands largely instead
of really to the development then the
existing building to the next to it
which is number 18 C Street also stands
quite protrude into the rear to
development the proposal is going to
align the rear of the application this
is the existing built form as it
currently stands you can see there's
trees quotes and if me on the East Wing
Commanders abrupt end on the west side
and the visual one-shot frontage is at
the front this is the front elevation as
being proposed the applicant is
proposing external alterations that
shopfront is presently the shop front it
has a degree of visual subdivision you
will see as layer and the slides
resulting from the centrally positioned
pillar which is this supporting the
overall an overhang under which the shot
from sets which is oblique the angled
inwards over side towards central door
the application is proposing to infill
do run forming a flat front is aligned
to the street akin to the other
neighboring buildings including the
listed building this were evolving the
shop-windows in line with the principle
of ation and each unit having its own
entrance door the South elevation is
proposed is presently it protrudes
outwards because of the wing this will
have a slightly extended the east wing
or in this case will protrude to the
same level and align the two wings
together this is being proposed as being
the entrance to the flats side elevation
is demonstrated that there is going to
be six meter development extension to
areia which will also introduce roof
lights to the shop front for the flats
above and also there will be alterations
to the other wing which all to
accommodate you
the proposed apartments this is how the
shop currently sits on the front sheet
Street as you can see the protruding
angles and there's only one entrance
door the main pillar holds it these are
the two windows to the one shot that
currently exists they proposed a world
longing this entire including two doors
and two shop frontage so they make two
shops this is a street view of sheet
Street facing from the West band words
this is the listed building adjacent
must feed through and this is the
conservation area this is the other side
of the street view listed building and
as you can see the concentration higher
and higher the shop relates to the area
this is the rear as it presently stands
the access agree and promote proposed
from here this is the car part within
violet a liberal street as you can see
this is a building where we are impose
we altered to in column had flats this
wing will be extended outwards to along
into the frontage as well as an
introduction in the middle for entrance
to the flats so that all that will be
aligned together or so there is a
proposed which when she's window you in
there
this is either currently sits that
really flat in words this is a building
which we were always just previously
talking about it which will this side
will extend no it was to the entrance
were we formed it virtue to this this is
the listed building adjacent to it and
how overlooks this is the proposed site
application and the development this is
a praise location planning you see how
opportunities are aligned small sort of
an elevation at which for the shop
entrance these are the car parks to area
and the small amount I mean each face
which includes been cycles and so forth
that's the end of the presentation and
slides updates
there has been a third-party
representation by mr. poppy Sharon she
objects to the development on the
principle is overdevelopment officer
recommendation is to grant permission
for the modification as the existing a1
retail unit and one of our story
extensions they're really property
together with the creation of four flats
on the upper floors of the building
subjects for conditions as outlined on
he's fifty forty agenda thank you thank
you Joe
we'll move on to our first speaker which
is Jane Cashmore companied by Chris
Lloyd I believe
good evening hi Jane
I'll see you know that the score three
minutes like a warning Thanks thank you
just before I start says mr. Lloyd the
applicant who's here for any questions
yeah good evening everybody
I wanted to primarily address the
objections which have been raised by a
third party and councilor st. the
objections relate to overdevelopment
lack of parking and the impact on
neighbors
first of all parking the site lies in
the central location in chip stone in
designing this proposal we've had
careful regard to the recent decisions
by the council and appeal decisions in
relation to proposals were born on to
bed dwellings and chip stone in
particular I draw your attention to
number 16 Sheep Street which is two
doors away and gain planning permission
in June four three four three flats with
no parking a car parking appraisal
submitted with that application
demonstrated that there are in excess of
60 spaces that are available for use
overnight within a 200 meter radius of
the site 32 of those spaces are
available within permit holder areas
meaning that residents owning a car
could also park in daytime hours if
needed were County Council highways
consider this is valid evidence for the
application before you this evening
there is also a repeat appeal decision a
few doors away at Manor Lodge from April
this year where the inspector said no
parking was needed for at uber dwelling
the council has no minimum parking
standards the evidence indicates there
is available parking in county highways
have raised no objection in view of all
this I can only conclude that the
development is acceptable with without
parking and a course with policy in
terms of over development the council
has no minimum amenity standards the
site as you can see on the plan on the
screen provides for adequate space for
bin storage cycles under grass community
space along with hard standing turning
to the impact on neighbors there is no
breach of any 25-degree rule the one new
site facing window will be obscured and
nan-oh
to 1.7 meters such that no overlooking
could arise proposed roof lights are
also at high level it's also material to
note that the existing 1st and 2nd floor
could be converted to two flats under
permitted development in addition to the
benefits of providing for dwellings in a
sustainable location there are other
positives of the scheme the splitting of
the larger retail unit into two is a
benefit as its more attractive with a
smaller floor space its use will remain
in a one use in accordance with policy
the proposal would be a visual
improvement to the street scene of sheep
Street second the emerging neighborhood
development plan identifies an
opportunity for additional Town Center
dwellings over retail and service units
this proposal meets that aim I hope
you're able to support your officers
recommendation thank you for listening
I've got one so you can't get away to
Harley could you confirm I didn't quite
hit properly when you said about the
overdevelopment did you say no standard
I couldn't quite catch what you see no
minimum amenity area standards on the
order for the car park the chipster is
part of my the car parts covered to my
technical services portfolio okay well
my connector that you keep on sneak in
the window but yes okay mr. Chappell I
can answer that thank you yeah no that's
fine not a problem sir right no further
questions I let off for good behavior
thank you very much
mr. chairman I'm going to start on the
terse note to respond to one of mrs.
cash Moore's comments as to how many car
parking spaces are available those car
parking spaces are provided by this
council under councilor brains portfolio
and they are provided for people that
work in the town they are provided the
people that actually come to shop in the
town they are not there a spare parking
spaces for residents and we had this the
other week when the previous application
that was referred to was considered and
there was a somewhat bizarre reference
to the number of parking spaces so I
asked you to discount her comments on
availability of car parking the
situation is this particular application
a problem point of clarification right
now the situation is here that this is a
shop that first of all doesn't have any
access it would appear certainly not in
the notes certainly not in the
presentation no rights of access across
the council's car park to this
particular location and it has it
doesn't have multiple residences above
it the previous application which you're
asked to compare did have a formal
access granted by the council and it did
have it did have you know some evidence
of availability of parking therefore the
two applications are quite different
misplaced it at a premium in ships than
the building that's going on means that
car parking is equally needed for the
purposes in which it was designed and
provided and under no circumstances
we'll I appreciate anybody on this
committee thinking that they can grant
planning permission because there is
availability in the public car box for
them to make up for the deficiency of
any car parking on the site
secondly if you look at the papers that
were shown by the case officer we have a
clear situation of a stone building in I
think on the or on the edge certainly in
it a conservation area and we have a
somewhat bizarre bland set of materials
so within the the this is new to me
tonight that presentation therefore I'm
not fully prepared and I've got little
time to compress it but I must ask you
to reject this application on the
grounds of the materials used it's a
very modernistic thing in a very old
part of the town where we're preserving
the character or attempting to preserve
the character and the location at those
particular locations
so therefore chairman we don't have if
you'd like a proper access across the
car we certainly don't have any car
parking and car parking is at a premium
there might be a possibility the County
Council might deal with these people in
the residence parking schemes that they
operate but no reference has been made
to this in the application so I presume
that it's ineligible and therefore that
is every reason why this application
should be totally and utterly refused
and I'm sorry chairman that I've had to
speak in such strident terms I was
prepared to speak a little more calmly
on the materials obviously looking at
the picture in front of us the drawings
and print of us it would appear that the
to the new extension would mirror the
materials of the other one would that be
an acceptable solution to you no because
it's not the materials that are
additional materials and what's more
the new extension is taking up what
limited car parking space they might
have round the back of those shops just
a supplementary on that particular point
how do they access that car parking
space at this moment I don't know how
the property accesses it says land the
car park has entrances directly from the
street and and these are paid car park I
might add I forgot to mention either
yeah no sorry the is the access to those
I think it was two parking spaces at the
rear of the property which is where the
extension is going to be now built if I
believe it's that access through the
council car park yes the access is
through the council car park that's the
only vehicular way in did you indicate
are you waving your pen just just a
clarification the parking on Sheep
Street that is County Council whereas
the parking at the rear here is District
Council is that correct yes the cop here
is the district council car park which
is a site there are meters in there and
it's charged for during the day the on
street parking in Sheep Street is
restricted to two hours for normal and
for unlimited access if you have a car
parking permit provided by the County
Council but I think you'll find there's
enough properties in Sheep Street that
already have permits to actually use up
the allocation that's the Perry thank
you chair good evening council st. can
you advise are there any restrictions in
overnight parking in the telegraph no
you've got three objections in the
papers but you you're drawing a
presentation you
or so objecting that the fact the
materials and will not in keeping with
the location the street scene that is
correct yes thank you because that was a
new thing that was presented to me by
the case officer thank you any more
questions
caster fielding it may be overnight
parking in Telegraph no it's painful
between the hours of 9 a.m. and 5 p.m.
it's a Shoppers car park which you know
paid for hour and you can deal with it
for longer but normally most people park
for an hour or two and that's the
tariffs reflects that thank you any more
questions thank you for your strident no
problem with it so and it's good to see
somebody getting so passionate about
this subject I believe and so thank you
very much that you get passionate about
parking because I know it's a severe
problem and you can't lighten it and we
can't give it away in the way that the
agent for the applicant was proposed it
was suggesting parking and that
particular photograph implies that we
have got some form of formal agreement
because the box has been blocked out in
what would appear to be our quote
unquote car park therefore there must be
some formal access to the rear of that
property from our car park is that
correct yes there are agreements to I
think believe 16 and 20 their easement
rights therefore their legal rights to
cross our property to their property
that's why there
I've got science keep clear ask first
about the carpark is that and yaks only
limit to the use or restriction I don't
believe so chair it may be referred to
us a shopper's carpark there's no
restrictions on who can actually use the
car part I would want except for
probably certain tonnage of vehicles etc
etc but normal vehicles can use it
normal people can use those thank you
you're doing well with that then I think
you've put your hand up next if the
development went ahead and they didn't
they couldn't park around the back there
would that area be lost no they've got
an easement right so they can access
that carpark through that keep clear
area if they were to do certain works
that I would imagine when they actually
do the works to that property they would
have to have some kind of agreement from
us because I'll need scaffolding
probably on our side of the car park to
actually do that so they'll need a
license to construct so they'll need
access rights for a while on outside of
the car park but at the moment going
through our car they do have an access
right and they will probably retain the
access right to get to the back of the
flats
it doesn't from the design we've seen it
doesn't look as if there's any room at
all for a car to go in there well there
is there is a about the back where the
bins will be and that won't be no cars
at all they will by the looks of the
plans they will not be parking at the
back of those flats that would be
parking all there in the car park or
somewhere in ships turn so I could just
ask the application isn't it funny that
they're not proposing any type of hiking
with the application is just for the
flats
can I just clarify on the material
selection because obviously the previous
speaker mentioned about materials now
I'm making an assumption this is the
reader that we were in the right slide
that Gathol on that but obviously that's
where the actual materials the extension
is going to be but will it be the same
material ie redbrick for the extension
and so therefore in keeping coke with a
counter unquote of the area or is it
going to be detrimental to the list of
buildings there if I just try and show
you the proposal so there you go that's
erratic red brick area there will be
zinc cut in and timber warden along the
windows just on the page bill Dominion
we had a previous planning application
on the other side of the street of
Telegraph Street where the windows were
that were an important aspect of the
conservation area which was a couple of
months ago surely is this not part of
the conservation area it is part the
conservation area but the officers
opinion is in deeper than the mid with
the building's adjacent and so forth it
would in question being is where you
think the materials would affect the
conservation area as a whole further
questions
illustration showing car parking spaces
yeah that's okay sorry just in case the
Perry first and they're not Kovalchuk
that's not again gorilla parking the
boundary there the red line I'm assuming
that that would be closed off for
vehicular access or would that be still
some access into our car park after the
event they still have an easement right
they're gonna need to get right any way
by vehicular or foot it's not going to
use it by vehicular they'll still use it
by foot okay Kelly thank you sorry I
think I mean it's a bit slow um on the
plan there is there any allocated
parking just for the flats did you
mention two parking spaces no elsewhere
and there's been no parking car parking
appraisal it's just going on what's been
done there's been no car parking
appraisal but the applicant does refer
to the appraisal was undertook at 16 a
cheap street this is referred to one
currently highway Safari and their
consultation response did say there was
sufficient parking spaces available from
that appraiser that was undertook 1683
okay with that I mean that that planning
allocated them for those flats and the
people that we're living there that's
extra spaces do you correct that in the
highway response from that I can
appraisal it's still even with that
additional accommodation at 16 a still
states that there is sufficient parking
for this
residential development as well in
relation to this application we've put
together yes okay thank you
okay Safari happy to move on now to the
debate and I see you're keen to start
thank you very much
somebody's somebody's got to start I'm
actually very sympathetic towards this
development I think one of the key
things that is particularly appealing
ships turn on stars become a really
vibrant market town for independent
retailers and one of the things
independent retailers are looking for a
small units and therefore if we just
take the sort of the the front frontage
of the retail space I think it actually
complements the the remaining parts of
Sheep Street because it actually Eve
evens it out and it it complements the
the retail units either side but to me
more importantly is that we create two
separate retail opportunities ships that
is all about attracting independent
retailers into the market town I wish
Stratford had far more independent
retailers and it's it's a key to me it's
a real key benefit to ship Stern to have
retail units that are small enough that
will attract independent retailers to
the town and keep it really really
vibrant we don't have any objection from
ships ninten Council there is a demand
for in town accommodation for people who
work in the town there's a lot of young
people and also a number of more elderly
people wanting to move into the town and
be close it's it's an area where is
self-sufficient someone who doesn't have
a car you know can can get to the bank
stuffy's can do all their business
there's bosses nearby I think it's been
very carefully thought thought through
I often park in Telegraph car park
myself never have a haven't had a
problem in finding a space in fact even
during the day but I suspect as
councillor st. mentioned you know it's
the people car parks are there for
people who work and shop it is also
pretty empty at night for people who
perhaps commute or work elsewhere that
there there is a space for them to park
without charges so I'm actually in favor
I think I think there's been a lot of
thought put into this and I like the
idea of the frontage creating two
smaller retail units to attract some
other entrepreneurial independent
retailers to the town and also provide
much-needed additional accommodation in
the town centre so I'll be in support of
the officers recommendation one of the
things that we we look at when residents
residences are developed is car parking
I think it's an overt of that develop
site there is there is car parking
around the back that they have a right
of access to and I think if properly
laid out that car parking should be used
I think trying to squeeze in as much as
they're trying to squeeze in is a node
of overdevelopment of the site and there
is perfectly good car parking around the
back that should be retained and be used
properly I'm against an hour refuse
catch the mouse
thanks miss chillin yeah I have to agree
with John fielding it I just feel it
over development of the site I'm not all
that keen on the on the materials being
used
you know this having to rely on a public
car part for their parking is just that
I think they're just making the word at
the moment just making use of it but
again I think to say we development so
was chairman of won't be sporting this
recommendation thank you I agree with
councillor Perry regarding the retail
element of the application and it is
important to encourage small independent
retailers and to meet use of that
fantastic shop space but I am concerned
regarding the residential element of it
being in Congress with the buildings
around it it is within a conservation
area and when there is such a premium on
parking two to utilize that space for
development and squash everything onto
that that plant is concerning so on
between two places the moment on this
sorry thank you it is interesting there
are many similarities between ships and
also regards parking and also the the
retail experience as well because
obviously have a number of independent
shops too so I support that aspect of it
the car parking is an interesting issue
we do have a problem in austere but very
similar to this where people come in in
the morning to work and they park in the
car park of course and then there's not
enough room for shoppers but I'm getting
the impression that this isn't actually
the necessarily the case in this
particular example or this case I've got
sorry I do have a sympathy with the
parking issue and it's something it's
never going to go away no not in our
lifetime say not mine so I'm like
counselor Donna I am a little bit
between two schools on this particular
one
I do wonder whether or not parking is
sufficient to refuse this particular
planning application though and whether
or not it would just be come straight
back to us as an appeal so I'm sort of
erring on the side of saying that I
don't think there's sufficient cause to
refuse it these at the moment I'll
listen to any more debate I dare to look
at mr. Nash will not talk about car
parks I'm precious about car parts I
don't in this house if there's no car
park in this application is it a to a
staff car parking and there's
regulations in this car park in the
daytime specifically to safeguard it
from parking 24/7 no return within three
hours I think that's for the first hour
and the second air I don't believe
there's any necessity to keep the space
clear there was no not going to be any
cars were laid into the development and
I think that's something good enough to
look at but I don't think it fails just
on car park oh yeah my two pairs worth
and I did take the liberty and asked
them come out during the presentation I
don't think it has asking the officer
what the mix of the flats would be it
seems that there were three one-bedroom
flats and two at one two-bedroom flats
so I just wonder how many extra cars
that would generate how much parking
that would generate I wouldn't in my
opinion you think that would be
excessive if had been open two bedrooms
or three bedroom that I could imagine
there would be a lot more cars catch the
cargo spoke about after I will give my
two pails about Salem where we've had a
development at the ball in to it-- flats
with very little onsite parking and ham
to rely on parking
at Wood Street which is another one
against the Ryans car parks and that
wouldn't seen as a particular issue then
and as far as I'm concerned I think I
think the parking issue can be overcome
I don't think is in light of the size of
the properties I don't think that's
particularly an issue I agree with care
to the peri with a property hat on an
estate agent hat on the flats above the
properties in shops in town are valued
and especially one-bedroom flats for the
people starting out and I know in South
on we've got a dearth of one-bedroom
flats which would go down a bit snapped
up like gold that's I think the phrase
is so I could see there are are some
negatives about this and might have some
concerns about the materials being used
but i'm mollie planning balance on happy
to support the officers recommendation i
know that the town council asked for a
condition to include not to obstruct
elevator car park during the
construction and I'd like that condition
put in if we determine it in favor of
the officers recommendation no two
parking services really access
it's a difficult one that is because
I'll probably need to use some part of
Telegraph streetcar park they would they
would need some part of the Telegraph
Street car park and us as the the owner
would have to grant them a license to
carry out certain works on our car park
to facilitate their works so the
condition is I mean they know everything
yes yeah
nothing on hazel most of us we're
thinking about that have we proposed a
any proposals on on this so thank you
I'm very happy to propose the granting
of this proposal with yeah I mean
inappropriate condition on on seeking
permission to apply for the construction
of I think it probably needs a
construction management plan anyway
because of busy times and access into
the car park so it might be that
construction materials need to be
delivered at a specific at specific
times of the day but I'll leave that I'm
very happy to leave that to the officers
to come up with the appropriate
recommendations I don't have an issue
with that chairman it's Grampian
condition yes they will need to seek our
permission so I think what's happening
regarding materials and conditions for
that because a few people mentioned they
weren't happy with the materials being
proposed given it's in a conservation
area well on the on the list of proposed
conditions there is a requirement to
provide sample materials so whilst the
plans give an indication of the
materials that are due to be used should
the application be proposed obviously
the officer would have final
determination in what those materials
were so we can secure that if needs be
it is listed mr. fielding proposed
refusal of the scheme on the grounds
that is overdevelopment I appreciate
it's being proposed for grant but I
would like to come in as a refusal
first ever second oh yeah I've been
advised that we've had a proposal for
accepting
is there anybody wanted to second catch
the cargo so we'll go through that
process first and then if that fails
we'll go back to do their professor so
yeah so we've got conditions if I'm
right in thinking those that are listed
which includes materials and then there
was a requirement for a construction
management plan so that we can establish
delivery times and also correct me if
I'm wrong but that they then seek
permission for the use of the carpod
during construction times correct okay
now I'm willing to give you that they've
I catch the right I'm mindful with four
flats and we talk about the business
store it's a sufficient room for the
bins or would it be communal there is
sufficient room let me just try say gay
was happy to rely on your kindness and
sight wise words to come up with a
sensible question oh and I think I
should be nice then before so well done
thank you for that so we've got a
proposal and a second that we go with
the officers recommendation with their
with the conditions we've talked about
so all those in favor one two three
chairman all those against one two three
Jim and any abstentions
yep so we note the abstentions
so it's them back to me and I'm not
minded to change my initial opinion so I
will go with the officers recommendation
to approve this application so and
cancel results to grant application 17 /
0 2 to 6 Oh f you are thank you Jeff
unto next item item 8 on the agenda
which is application 17 4 / 0 1 9 8 0 /
ful 46 I Church Street ships announced
our change the views of ground floor
from a1 retail shop to micro pub cross
a4 and are presented officer so thank
you John thank you Jeff this is an
application again within ships non-star
it's to change the use of the property
here ground floor level from an a1
retail unit into a microp up as you can
see the sites within the conservation
area of ship stone and within the town
centre boundary it adjoins a listed
building as you can see to the north the
existing shop layout is as though to the
main accesses off Church Street here and
you've got the retail area and sort of
staff facilities at the back the
proposed change of use is just internal
alterations so the retail area would be
reconfigured to have a bar toilet area
would remain there for patrons as well
as stuff there's no external changes
proposed to the application this is the
application site they were looking at
here so it's this ground floor unit
that's currently a 1 it's been vacant
for a while and it's proposed to convert
that everything would remain as is
become a micro pub this is a view from
down Church Street so this is the listed
building as you can see it's in a row of
similar retail units at ground-floor
flats above the properties here and
residential further at Church Street
this is the rear area so it's the salmon
pink building is the application site so
again you've got the flats above the
property you've got this rear access
door that goes into the unit and there's
a shared access that comes around here
and serves the car garage that's it to
the rear here as well as the rear of
these properties there's obviously a
right of access for the for the unit
over this currently
and that's proposed to remain as far as
I'm concerned is the end of the
slideshow good so that was a Maiko
presentation but we'll move on to our
first speaker which is against the saint
again
Chairman I oppose this largely on the
grounds that it is not particularly town
center although it replaces a shop it is
on the cusp of residential properties in
in the particular area and the shot we
saw around the back I always understood
was private and private car parking so
therefore for the local residents it's a
bit of a complex area however my big
concern is that if this occupies or if
this becomes this sort of special type
of a for pop I'm not quite certain it is
a change of use therefore it requires
careful consideration but again I'm
sorry to beat on about it but I'm gonna
go on about parking again right because
I know my ward
I know I know ship Stern and I know that
constraints there are on parking and
it's a bloody sight more difficult than
it is in Ulster I might say to council a
cargo but the issue is that the entrance
to this particular property is roughly
where Church Street joins Stratford Road
and he's on a very tight Bend you'll
have seen from the photographs that were
in the presentation that there are cars
parked along the front and in fact it's
a bit of a tight and difficult area
that's right you see it so consequently
there is a kind of extended lay-by there
for parking but it's always fully
occupied now I don't believe that people
are going to walk to this facility
people are going to drive to it and when
they get there like any other pub
they're going to have somewhere to park
and most pubs even the traditional ones
in the middle of ships have a reasonable
amount
of off street car parking this has none
now I expect on the city of the back and
listen to you saying can you just refuse
it on parking but I think this is a
material consideration a very big
consideration because where that car is
the great car on the screen by the the
house with all the stuff the vinery over
the front of it right that is virtually
behind a blind Bend so when you drive
into ships and from where I live you
come round that bend into that area and
suddenly you hit busyness it's on the
edge because people can't park in the
town centre so they pop right up a long
way from the edge and the edge of town
and as a consequence it is a key issue
therefore I personally think that the
retail output there would not have
generated the kind of traffic that a pub
will need to actually be viable
therefore you can guarantee there will
be a demand for parking and that in
itself makes this change of use
completely unsuitable
you did know thank you very much
Thank You counselor st. can you just
advise are the above the retail outlet
do you know are they are they flats or
offices above the retail space
do you know haven't had good practice
that leaflet delivery in that area I
would argue they're probably flats they
have lots of little letter boxes around
the back in clusters thanks for sure and
Chris it the the property next door the
the very large house have they made any
comment to you a pup being open next
autumn this is the wrong answer you
caught me out but no they have they are
known to me
and on the other side you've got you've
got a couple of other shops as well
right it's a bit there's a probability
we have got allowances for this in the
core strategy is a probability of a
shopping area contracting thank you
thank you Ken staff L don't think it's
the pairing ships turn I believe is
served by hostile areas is there another
I certainly aren't the professional
expert on this front study I've looked
at the practicality oh you want better
sense of me again are you Jim and giving
a very brief looked at it from
point of view of the public demand and
access to it rather than whether there's
room for another pub the pubs in the in
the town are largely well provided well
supplied and well patronized so
therefore there's a good balance there
already without the extra yes my my
question relates to the Town Council
which I see has made a no representation
console teasing I just wondered whether
that was if you attended that the the
meeting was that unanimous and were
there any other comments raised by yeah
I did I will answer your question by
saying if you look at the minutes of the
Town Council you will see they make no
representation to about 90 percent of
the planning applications that come past
there I I do have some ideas as to that
and I find it very frustrating but I'm
gonna say no more before the Chairman
shuts me up again against the Perry's
procedure I was gonna ask a very similar
question I do note that you said you
knew the area well he went round with
your leaflets oh so you knew the area
well would you leave this and there are
right third party comments objecting
from local residents so on a from the
balance point you do sir the questions
or are we happy to move on Thank You
cancer st. as usual thank you very much
that's me again
I noticed in the committee report
highways have a an objection can you
just provide presumably an update on
that
yeah and originally the plan included a
disabled ramp on the outside of the
front door which highroads said was
going to be a highways obstruction I
went back to the applicant and they
confirmed it's a removable ramp so
they'll put out when a patron needs it
who needs to gain access that way so
they removed it from the plans and
highways then updated their comments
ferm they had no objection
I can't forward like John yeah it's just
like I think there's a typo on the on my
dates for the highways comments their
initial response I think is correct and
then they updated one should be I think
the 17th of the night does anybody know
what the answer the microbe would be
considering we're looking at your
residential area yes page 61 six four
o'clock to nine Monday to Saturday and
four o'clock till 7:30 on Sunday okay
you're not the first to do that kind of
slow down I'm sure but no please to be
assistance on that one that's the
building this area has flooded and I
know there is concern about flooding to
be taken into account the the garage and
the far side was closed down in the
floods a few years ago also the fact is
that beer is a very strong as a waste
product having dealt with a micro
brewery what details have been taken
into account with regards to the waste
products and also flooding I think
flooding has been covered on page 62 in
terms of the waste products do you mean
the empty cakes that would be taken away
from the pub or I presume it would just
be going down the sink that's provided
it's in the currently in the building
though there's no no further details in
relation to that at all thank you John
to move on to the debate now did I see
I'll start
thanks for chill yeah it's very odd
about this isn't it
very odd micro pub there I am I'm
grappling with trying to find a reason
why she refuses but I can't see there's
a again it's probably up through fusion
I can't see this as a viable business
in the opening hours are very short so
obviously they're not gonna annoy the
neighbors next door but I just wanted to
come back and wanting to extend their
opening hours but it just seems a very
odd place to have a micro pop okay I'm
struggling to find planning reason I
shouldn't have won that again the
parking issue is a problem I'll listen
to what everybody else says mr. chairman
I'm confused two kinds another moment
game back onto the parking round the
rear the country councillor Saint record
was private is that the case sorry yeah
it's probably owned by the people who
own the the car business at the rear but
I think there is no the applicants may
reference to a right of access over
there not for parking just a a right to
access regime for deliveries and that
sort of thing thank you again
Ulster as their first we had an
application a few months ago and exactly
the same as this small shocked in the
high street micro pub and we were
thinking what on earth do they want to
do that for because we've got as you may
know also got quite a number of pubs in
the end they actually withdrew it and I
do wonder whether the viability was was
an in
a factor there however exactly the same
parking on the street for example car
parking around the rear we couldn't find
a reason to actually refuse it there was
no real reason to refuse him and if it
does fail then that's just a business
decision and that's the reasoning me if
we put behind it I'm afraid I'll have to
do the same here please let's see the
plan officers put a condition into the
areas of opening and that is that not
the licensing authority decide that not
the Planning Department it can be I mean
we've put it on as as a planning reason
because obviously it's close to
residential properties and we feel that
the sort of restricting the opening of
ours will ensure there'll be no sort of
noise nuisance and an obnoxious sort of
anti-social behavior to to those
neighboring properties which is why
we've put on after say I'm struggling
with this application but also
struggling to find a reason to refuse it
I'd much rather see it as a coffee shop
I think you'll be far better serving
nice cakes and coffees and that sort of
thing but maybe the micro pop will serve
nice coffees and but it's just it's very
odd because it's he doesn't kind of sit
with the rest of the neighboring
establishments next door by virtue of
the opening hours four o'clock till nine
o'clock Monday to Saturday and four
o'clock to 7:30 on a Sunday I'm quite
perplexed as where the business is going
to come from you know pubs these days
make money out of their food so lunch
lunch is off the menu I can see and
you've got to eat your dinner pretty
quick if they're serving anything
because you've got to be out by nine
o'clock but as I sound I am struggling
because the only reason I can see for
refusal will be
adverse impact on and on the neighboring
amenities but that's not strong enough
to refuse it but as a it's got to come
forward to licensing I'm just perplexed
by the business plan of these applicant
and I think a coffee shop would be far
more appropriate at least it would have
shall we say more appeal to the genre of
ships turn on star but I can't find a
robust planning reason to refuse it I do
like that where genre accounts the Perry
but we'll move on to Connor
Thank You um forgive me if this is
because I'm you know not up to speed
with with a certain application for
businesses but I know of the really
rigorous viability studies the rural
applicants have to go to when they're
trying to expand their businesses does a
new business such as this not have to go
through viability study just to prove
it's a viable isn't it doesn't know
thank you
it's coming very clear in both in in
kind and rather than Ulster is this
problem of cars and parking and
developing properties there is no
concise plan that we were putting
forward and yet again we are we are
filling narrow streets with cars it
seems to me a real problem that we've
got to look where's the evidence of that
well that statement they actually feel
what and filled it firming the streets
the cars what wonder where that come
from a parking is is is in short supply
in a number of places and we've just had
it in in Kyneton where we've put into
there's an application for several flats
on in an old bank and again that was
causing problem with housing we're
having the problem here with with
parking and I know okay Telegraph Street
is around the corner but again there are
yeah
striction yeah and I don't necessarily
agree with that especially Ben's there
was an existing premises before I don't
know they open and I was not one P
asking that but there was a premise that
was serving the public so there must
have been some form of traffic movement
to that I don't know how long it's been
empty but then what's been some form so
we don't know the material difference
between the amount of traffic generated
for the previous shopfront
compared to this one so I'm not exactly
convinced by that argument we can have a
point to stop this going on any further
I'm going to propose that we accept the
officers recommendation for a grant
just bear with us a second we're just
clarifying some condition
there was condition potential condition
regarding the ramp on page 60 note noted
ramp is movable arms amputated need
rather than permanent fixture we've just
been made aware that the actual ramp has
been taken off normal taken in if we
couldn't require a file that make sure
it's the condition then it doesn't cause
a trip hazard but is there when it's
needed and on request so I think that's
that's released all wood we've had a
proposal have we got a seconder I can
catch the mouse just to comment miss
chill this ramp I mean do you see
they're gonna take it in and out so soon
it's a disabled person come to I think
they can leave it out all night somebody
fall over it there's a walking past
that's what I feel but in the highway
it's cause an obstruction which is a
criminal offence so the county could
enforce that condition against them or
even the District Council so it seems a
fair and reasonable condition to me I'm
trying to find him reason to give refuse
it and I just repeat my previous comment
that we've had a proposal to accept this
application and seconded by Councillor
cargo all those in favor of agreeing to
the application 1 2 3 4 chairman 5
chairman 1 chairman
one chair one committee resolves to
grant application 1 7 / 0 1 9 8 / fu
well on the agenda
this application is 17 / 0 as there are
6 3 2 / f UL labret ban lebryk roy
bishops each in turn propose change of
use of redundant agricultural barn to
holiday that unassociated works the
presenting officer is Andy Carter Thank
You chair right on the image in front of
you the application site is indicated by
the black dot it's to the north of
Bishops itching t'n this plan shows you
the access road extending from the
highway all the way up to the site it
goes under the railway line to extend to
the rural building which is proposed to
be changed to a holiday let another
location plan that just indicates
indicates the blue land as well which is
owned by the applicant a closer in plan
existing plan on the left they're
showing the quite modest rural building
and on the right which is for the
conversion of the building change of use
to holiday let and a small curtilage
around it to allow for two parking
spaces and a turning arrangement those
are the existing elevations and those
are the proposed elevations so the large
opening the
and elevation there will be closed with
some glazing the introduction of roof
lights to allow the light to the bed
deck which would be inserted into the
building to allow some sleeping
accommodation and this plan just shows
how works lain currently connects with
elaborate Road some photographs of the
existing bond or buyer as I've been told
it's also called it's quite a quite a
small rusticated building and then this
is an image of the beginning of the
access track so this is start the access
track from the works kata Tjuta
cottages which I can show you on the
plan shortly so this is a locked gate to
control the access track killed as I
understand it remain locked during the
should the application be successful and
there would be a management arrangement
whereby people who are letting the
holiday let would have a key to open and
close that gate the access track
continues under the railway line as was
shown on the earlier plan continues
towards the field and here we have so
not quite in sequencer two approaches
here we have going back slightly laborat
road and works lane so that's the extent
of the highway and there finally is the
site location so it's quite distant from
Bishops which in turn and hence the
length of the access track application
the proposal is to grant subject to the
conditions that the in the officers
report thank you Andy urn move on to our
first speakers which is catch the sue
Wilson and cancel that Adam Duvall from
Bishop position to the parish castle
[Applause]
thank very much counselor Soph I don't
think you'd think would get here but we
eventually got here so thank you for
that's right yes so you have three
minutes between you and which like a
warning at 30 seconds for tonight so
these were the ones that were provided
to me by committee services in the last
week Alison Clarke parish-clerk
submitted a set of photographs right um
I can scan through these if do any of
these ring a bell well they ring a bell
in the sense that yes they are the
location but they're not the photographs
that I had prepared to go with my ride
the engine yeah well we're just so Jenna
seconds if we can see something farnum's
you've just there was another few
minutes
can you send them all to anybody
why sweet gone through services
hello don't if we can't get out I
suggest we do further need to know and
I'll put them I know we've done it
before but if it's relevant we need to
do it nothing else a sensible suggestion
and now I can obviously sympathize with
with the parish council for coming over
three times sit here all night so if we
do defer I would like to ask if it could
be the first item on the agenda if we
can just there was rather none - John
come back again which we might often if
we have a measurement first authorities
yeah - or like to say few words please
sorry - ah I know we're trying to
accommodate the Parish Council
Mississippi and it mix up somewhere
along the line and I do apologize for
that but I think what we are proposing
to do is slightly irregular and I'm not
happy with it as a big loss therefore I
think we should follow the normal
process and believe that we should defer
this application unfortunately again and
then we can come back and consider in
the right way that's my thoughts of it
but the only provides that I would like
to add is that we make sure it's first
item on the agenda at the next at the
earliest possible meeting but we give
the applicants sorry the objectors
opportunity to change we confirm with
the objectors that we've got the actual
photographs we've got everything in
apple-pie order so they don't have a
wasted journey again so I'm sorry to
have to propose this and I would like to
have this sorted out tonight but I think
in the case of natural justice we have
to defer to make sure you get your
proper opportunity to put your case
forward with your own photographs so
we've got a proposed in a second all
those in favor
that's unanimous
right Thank You chair thank you thank
you
we've got one more item yes number
number 10
urgent business yeah you rolled it don't
worry cancer site make sure that cat's
failed in building thank you
when I worked in the virgin business
which I have agreed with myself that I
bring forward that one person here is
actually leaving the organization to go
to pastures new and we'd like to thank
so yes the Carter is leaving us see well
thank handy for all this work over the
Tommy's been with us and his wise words
and just Lutter give him a round
applause and wishing
[Applause]